[Music]
unbelievable stuff when you're badass
what he did that was so hard as he was
able to eliminate the prejudice that you
think that you're special in one
location versus another or that you're
privileged or poor you have a preference
you know of a preferred point of view
right so the hardest thing for people to
think about is to remove that sort of
bias and to think instead you know more
abstractly right it's really amazing so
what we were going to do was tell you
about about this on a train but instead
we got a train coming now oh okay so now
if you look over there yeah that's the
Manhattan Bridge and you'll see a train
coming across so you makes you imagine
an experiment where you have a mirror at
the bottom and a mirror on at the top of
the Train and you shine a beam of light
from one to the other it reflects back
and forth straight up and now yeah this
is an iPhone this is a very old
fashioned you know I watch and so it's
keeping the time on the moving train you
see just going straight up for now but
we off the train are trying to watch
that happen and we'll see the beam of
light emanate from down here and then go
at an angle hit the mirror there and
then come down then hit the mirror back
in the same spot in the same spot
because the mirror mullah Maris movie
yeah if you look at the bars on the
bridge if the train was going the right
speed the light beam would actually
follow those diagonal right hit the top
mirror which should now move and it
would hit the bottom there but it would
be exactly on those supports I like that
there it's a relativity dance
everybody's doing I'm quitting
all right I was like a man okay so now
so what does that tell us right about
the universe when we look at light
travel in that what what what was
Einstein's is very clear we've we have
two people disagreeing what the light is
doing that's what I'm saying once people
say this just going straight up and down
we said no it's not so that's the guy
sat on the train he's sitting in the
seat he's watching light just going up
and down and we and that's all he says
all right and we're not on the train and
we see the light doing this if I see it
going just like we saw earlier
[Music]
the speed of light right
okay which is the constant right yes
therein lies the rub because the two
perspectives are at odds a parent or
it's seemingly but the constant is the
speed of light and we know that's a
constant we all measure the speed of
light no matter what no matter what no
matter where we are no matter how we're
moving or not moving or not move
everybody measures the same speed of
light right if that's the case then how
is it possible for the light beam to go
from the bottom of the Train to the top
what is that distance is that right and
we say that beam of light went on an
angle the hypotenuse right we all know
the hypotenuse is bigger than the leg of
the triangle right right exactly
right yep right so now from that as a
thought experiment knowing the speed of
light what we are able to glean and
determine mathematically is the closer I
am to that my clock is ticking more
slowly yes
the closer is the faster you the faster
rate of Louvain right so in other words
when I say closer I am I mean like I'm
on the train so I am that light there's
got another train coming now I copy okay
just imagine the
right and as you approach the speed of
light you'll be running away from our
point of view from the light pulse right
nearly as fast as the light pulse is
trying to make it to your mirror and
will think your clock stopped there you
go